let's bring in our panel former border
patrol agent rosemarie pepperdine who
worked in the tucson arizona sector for
25 years and national border patrol
council president brandon judge
rosaria i wanted to hear a little bit
about your decision to leave
the border patrol i know that i've read
that it was a lifelong call-in for you
that you loved the job but that it had
changed
yes the last year for 25 years i've
loved the job i show up every day i love
what i was doing um enforcing the law
what i was sworn to do and the last year
has really changed in the last year i
was more disgruntled so i can understand
those videos coming out i was not happy
going to work
um
we swore
an oath to protect the border or to
enforce the immigration laws and it
doesn't matter there's a republican or
democrat in office we should be doing
that and we haven't been doing that and
i unlike others had the ability to leave
and i decided to retire in december i
just want to ask you another question
rosemarie before i get to brandon
in your experience in 25 years have you
ever seen a situation like this
no i haven't i have not seen the morale
this bad and it's not just at my station
or my sector it was throughout the
border patrol everywhere you saw um
people who just weren't happy with what
was going on i mean we're risking our
lives every day catching human smugglers
drug smugglers and for what so they can
be released it was just a slap in the
face to us
i'll get right back to you rosemary
brandon
you've been saying this to us on air for
for a while now but does it feel like
it's reaching some sort of a fever pitch
i think it's good that the secretary
went down to the border to talk to them
or at least listen but when he goes back
to washington it doesn't seem like
anything changes and we're now you know
in the 13th month of this presidency
soon to be 14th
and nothing is going to change if you
look right now station wide nationwide
there is so much anger so much
frustration you can go to any border
patrol station and you can actually feel
the tension
every single time a u.s citizen
overdoses we feel it every single time a
u.s citizen is harmed by an illegal
border crosser we feel it we want to
protect the american public but our
hands are tied and it's tied because of
political aspirations and frankly it's
tied because of career aspirations of of
career employees that all they want to
do is move up that's wrong we want to
protect the american public but right
now we just can't do it rosemary how
dangerous is the situation that we would
face if you had even more of the agents
get take a deci make a decision like
you've done to leave the border patrol
even though you'd love the job but it's
just not a job you feel like you can do
and you hold look yourself in the mirror
at night knowing that you aren't allowed
to do what you're supposed to be doing
yeah i think um it's going to be very
dangerous because we're already short
we're thousands of agents short so we're
definitely the more people that are
leaving we're not replacing those agents
that are leaving so
your manpower is drilled to nothing and
you have agents who are covering miles
and miles of border by themselves and
this wasn't happening you know four
years ago
and i don't want to make it political
but under trump at least he was willing
to reach out and speak to us and find
out what we needed and the resource that
we were needing and whatever we needed
to do our job easier and now we're not
getting anything it's like they're more
worried about the ukrainian border than
they are about our own southern border
rosemary what is your greatest fear
right now as the borders is continues to
be open like this
i worry for the fellow agents i worked
with you know i worry about them not
only
their safety in the field but mentally
you know because it's a tough job you
know and right now not having the
support of
your upper management including
including chief ortiz and higher-ups in
the administration it makes it very
difficult
well brandon thank you for being here
with rosa maria we're gonna have to
leave it there but we'll have you both
back thank you and rosemary
congratulations on making a very tough
decision i'm sure that they are glad to
have you still as a friend thank you
thank you
thank you dana